is string theory really the answer
where do you fall on this like how do
you make sense of this puzzle why do you
think it has fallen out of favor yeah so
i don't i would actually challenge the
statement that's fallen out of favor i
would say that
any
field of research when it's new and it's
the the bright shiny
bicycle that no one has yet seen on that
block yeah it's going to attract
attention
and
the news outlets are going to cover it
and students are going to flock to it
sure but as a as a field matures it does
shed those qualities because it's no
longer
as novel as it was when it was first
introduced 30-40 years ago
but you need to judge it by a different
standard you need to judge it by
is it making progress on foundational
issues deepening our understanding of
the subject and by that measure string
theory is is is scoring very high
now at the same time you also need to
judge whether it makes contact with
experiment as we discussed before too
and on that measure we're still
challenged so
i would say that
many strengthers myself included
are are very sober about the theory it
has the tremendous progress that it had
30 40 years ago that hasn't gone away
but we've become
better equipped at assessing
the long journey ahead
and that was something that we weren't
particularly good at back say in the 80s
look when i was just starting out in the
field
there was a sense of
physics is about to end
string theory is about to be the be-all
and end-all final unified theory and
that will bring this chapter to a close
now i have to say i think it was more
the younger physicists who were saying
that some of the more seasoned even if
they were pro-strengthening at the time
i don't know if they were rolling their
eyes but they knew
that it was going to be a long long
journey i think people like you know
john schwartz one of the founders of
strength theory michael green no
relation to me founders of the theory
edward whitton you know one of the main
people driving the theory back then and
today
i think they knew that we were in for a
long haul
and and that's
the nature of science quick hits that
resolve everything
few and far between and so if you were
in
for
the quick
solution to the big questions of the
world then you would have been
disappointed and i think there were
people who were disappointed and moved
on and work on other subjects if we were
in in the way that einstein was in
for a lifetime of investigation to try
to see
where
what the answers to the deep questions
would be
then i think string theory has been a
rich source of material that has kept
so many people deeply engaged in moving
the frontier forward there's a few
qualities about string theory which are
weird
i mean a lot of physics is just weird
and beautiful so let me ask the question
what do you as most beautiful boss
string theory well but what attracted me
to the theory at the outset
beyond it's putting gravity and quantum
mechanics together which i think is um
it's true claim to fame at least on
paper it's able to do that
what attracted me to here was the fact
that it requires extra dimensions of
space
and this was an idea that
intrigued me
in a very deep way even before i really
understood what it meant
i somehow
had i mean talk about sort of the
emotional part of consciousness and the
cognitive part in some perhaps you call
it strange in some strange emotional way
i was enamored with einstein's general
relativity the idea of curved space and
time before i really knew what it meant
it just spoke to me i don't know how
else to say it
and then
when i subsequently learned
that people had thought about more
dimensions of space than we can see and
how those extra dimensions would
be vital to a deep understanding of the
things that we do see in this world four
five six dimensions might explain why
there are certain forces and particles
and how they behave
to me this was like amazing utterly
amazing and then when i learned that
strength theory embraced all these ideas
embraced the general theory of
relativity embraced quantum mechanics
embraced the possibility of extra
dimensions
then i was then i was hooked and so when
i was a graduate student we would just
spend hours
we i mean a couple of other graduate
students and myself who had uh have sort
of worked really well together at oxford
in england we would we would work these
enormous numbers of hours a day trying
to understand the shapes of these extra
dimensions the geometry of them what
those geometrical shapes for the extra
dimensions would imply for things that
we see in the world around us and it was
a it was a heady heady time and and that
kind of excitement has sort of filtered
through over the decades but i'd say
that's really
the the
part of the theory that i think really
hooked me most wrongly
you